MALE SPEAKER: Thanks for
being here this afternoon.
And today we're
pleased to welcome
Dr. T, a very special
guest from Minneapolis.
Dr. T was born in
Jerusalem, Israel.
He has two doctorate degrees.
One, in Chiropractic, and the
other one, in General Medicine.
Dr. T's specialties is in
health, medicine, nutrition,
and sustainability.
Dr. T had been traveling
extensively, offering
medical care and studying
nutrition practices
around the world.
In the West, we are dealing
with all kinds of stress,
mostly related to work.
Even Google, being the best
company to work for in 2014
according to the "Fortune"
magazine-- we still
feel the stress,
with a smiley face.
On the other hand,
the people in Nepal,
they have a different
type of stress in life,
and that's what I call
everyday life stress.
And, for example, they have
one of the slowest internet
services in the world,
and the internet
was introduced to Nepal in 1994.
And even as of today,
yet their internet speed
is the second slowest in the
world, just behind Libya.
And then, the second
problem they have
is, on average,
most people only get
about 9 to 12 hours of
electricity per day.
So, you can imagine living in
that type of an environment,
and even before these
challenges in life.
But the people in
Nepal are still
pretty happy and
extremely friendly.
And you can find, in
their greeting tradition,
for example, they do
not shake hands or hug.
What they would do is
they close their palm,
and then bow their
head, and say Namaste.
So today, we're lucky to have
Dr. T to share his childhood
experience in
Nepal and then what
we can learn from these people
about the health and also
the stress issue.
And then with that, I would
like to welcome Dr. T to Google.
DR. TEL-OREN: Thank you.
I know that you're
here for many reasons.
Some of you are here because
you want to know about stress,
and some are here
because you want
to know about the
Himalayas, and some
want to know about
the skin, and some
want to know about vitality.
So, how do we weave all
those things together
in just a short talk?
Normally, each one of them
could be a two or three hour
discussion.
So, we have to be a
little more concise
and be rapid in
our presentation.
And we need to realize what's
truly important in life.
What is it makes
people really stressed?
Why are we stressed?
Because we take on more
than we can handle.
Because we have a
lot of expectations
that are put upon us or
that we decide to adopt.
Because we want to Excel.
Because we want to
get appreciation.
Because today people would love
us for what we manufacture,
what we produce.
So, we have to get results.
We are very result
oriented in our society
and if we don't
perform according
to expectation, distress.
Even if we have the best food
in the world and the places
to get suntan, it's not enough.
So, we need to start
thinking about what's
really important to engage in
and to adopt above and beyond
the day-to-day routine of taking
more and more responsibilities
upon ourselves, which is the
main cause for stress in people
who are productive, and
young, and relatively healthy.
Of course, when you
have stress, you
have the physiological and
psychological consequence.
Many people have back
problems and insomnia.
Many people have stomach
upset and headaches.
A lot of people have
palpitation anxiety attack.
A lot of young
people that I see are
suffering from mood disorders.
They simply can't handle the
pressure of the daily life.
And that's not their fault.
It's the fault of
our physiology.
We're not made for that.
We are hardwired, in
our brain, to handle
quick and severe or
extensive stress, that
then abates and disappears.
That's what we are
designed to have in nature.
And we all came from
nature, like it or not.
We came from a place where
we had severe risk of death,
instantly, and then 10 minutes
later that risk passes away.
And if we survived
it, we can relax.
Today we don't have
that opportunity.
If the stress lasts too
long and it is too severe,
the results are extreme.
They've done studies
with mice and they
saw that when the mice are under
severe stress for too long,
after just several
hours of extreme threat,
those mice had three
severe anatomical changes.
In volution of the
reticuloendothelial system,
meaning everything shrinks
in the immune system organs.
Like the thymus, shrinks
rapidly and you could see it.
The adrenal glands, which
are associated with stress,
with the output of stress
hormones, starts swelling
and you see it rapidly, visibly,
anatomical growth, hypertrophy,
of the adrenals.
And the last of the visible
signs, is wounds and open sores
and bleeding ulcers in
the digestive system.
Now this is visible.
Imagine what is not visible.
Imagine all the little
things, the changes,
that happen in the body with our
circulation, with our hormones,
with our neurology.
All those things that happen
that are not visible in mice
within just a few
hours of severe stress.
And this is what we are
enduring in our society
because our stress
is interminable.
It continues, unabated.
We don't know when
to shut it down
because our responsibilities
and the tasks
we have to engage in on
a daily basis don't end.
On the contrary, we keep adding
on and on and on because we
want to excel, we want to
get respect and appreciation
from the jobs, from the
peers, from our friends,
from our family.
Everybody expects
something out of us.
We just don't know where to
let go and how to let go.
So, we go to all of those
methods of stress management
because we have those symptoms.
We can't sleep at night,
we need stimulants
to stay up during
the day because we're
so tired when we wake up.
If we wake up from
a night of no sleep
If you need to drink coffee
or take any stimulants to feel
that you can go
through the day, you're
not getting enough sleep
or poor quality of sleep.
And most people today
need stimulants every day,
whether it's caffeine,
coffee, chocolate,
or other such stimulants.
What are they doing?
They're pressing on the gas
pedal when the tank is empty.
They're forcing us into
the stimulation that
resembles a stress
response, which tells us
that we have a
little more energy.
Our blood supply is
slightly richer in glucose,
so we can bring more
energy to the muscles
for the fight-or-flight
that doesn't exist.
And that is the
stimulant that we always
take thinking it's good for us
because it makes us feel high,
but it's only necessary
because without it we plummet,
and we get tired, we
crash throughout each day.
Sounds familiar to some
of you, doesn't it?
That is not where you want
to be because over time all
of these conditions associated
with the physiological and
emotional stress are
going to simply make
you either fat, or tired,
chronically fatigued,
or having chronically suppressed
immune system resulting
in cancer.
People always go through
these three phases
of general adaptation syndrome.
The first phase is
just being under stress
but not knowing it.
The second, is having the
stress and having those symptoms
of fatigue, and
aches, and pains,
and digestive
complaints, et cetera.
The third phase is when there's
complete systematic break down.
The adrenals are overwhelmed.
They cannot create more of these
hormonal outputs of stress.
At that point,
people either develop
chronic fatigue syndrome
or fybromyalgia,
they become bedridden,
they totally
lose their
functionality, or they
have other severe chronic
condition, or they get cancer.
That's the third phase.
Most people today who are
under significant stress,
are already high
on the second phase
of this general adaptation
syndrome, also known as GAS,
and they are very dangerously
close to phase three.
I see today a lot of young
people in their '20s and '30s
who already are coming
into phase three
and wondering
where it came from.
Not realizing how much of
it is related to the stress
that they're suffering from.
And this is the stress
that is typically
in affluent countries.
We are all suffering
from affluenza.
And we really want
to change that.
We want to start moving
towards simplicity.
It's not always easy when we
have everything available right
in front of us to
just pick and choose.
Sometimes too many choices
is a stressful thing.
You want to just
be told, do this.
You don't want to know
too much information.
Just give me what I need.
But you have too many options.
That is a stress
because you want
to live life to the fullest.
You want to
experience everything.
While people in other countries
don't have that opportunity.
People in Nepal are always
having very few options
to eat, to see.
They never travel much.
They never go on an airplane,
they can't afford it.
So, they stay in one village
in the remote rural Nepal
and they never get out
of that environment.
Maybe once or twice a year
they would travel all the way
to Kathmandu, the
capital of Nepal.
And that's about it.
Those people are always
seeing the same trees,
the same houses,
the same mountains.
They wake up and
everything is predictable.
Now you would say-- and you'd
be correct-- is predictability
always a good thing?
Is nature predictable?
And you'd be right to ask
that because the answer is no.
And I've never said
that their life
is perfect out there in Nepal.
They have a lot of
their own challenges.
But their existence appears
to you to be predictable.
In reality, it's not.
They have constant
change in their life.
Every day brings numerous,
unpredictable events.
They never know if the food will
be good, if there will be food.
They never know
who they're going
to meet coming to
visit their village.
They have a lot of changes
in their environment.
Not just with the seasons,
but with survival.
Every time they walk on the
trail, something happens.
They might have to
confront a mule or a cow
or water Buffalo that might
push them off the trail.
Or they may just have a
landslide that will take down
a whole village and they
would have to somehow make do.
They're always on the survival
mode without even knowing it.
But it's a different
type of survival mode.
It's the kind that brings
change continuously,
where change is expected where
the unpredictable is expected.
Therefore, it is
not so stressful
when you see new things.
Let's contrast
that with Americans
who are accustomed
to their routine.
Every day they have
to get in their car,
drive, go from 9:00
to 5:00, drive back,
stop on the way in the coffee
shop, go to get some bagels.
Those people are doing exactly
the same thing every day.
They are creatures of habit.
But as soon as something
happens that is different,
they can't handle the stress.
They go berserk.
So, they need to drink
alcohol or take some pot.
Drink, smoke some pot
to feel more relaxed
because they can't
handle change.
In nature, we have
to handle change
because from every bush might
be an animal jumping out
at us-- under every tree.
Or every time we have to run
away we have to be prepared,
have to be alert, all the time.
When you get used to
that constant change,
you stop being stressed.
So, this is one thing
I like to teach people,
to keep making your life varied.
Increase variety,
complexity, in your life.
Allow things not to be simple,
while you live a simpler
lifestyle.
Sounds like a contradiction,
but it's the truth.
Simplify your life in what
you take on, but increase
the variety so that
you are accustomed
to the unpredictable.
Go outdoors into nature.
Many people will tell
you that to reduce stress
you have to either
meditate, or do mindfulness,
or hypnotherapy, or guided
imagery, or Tai Chi.
There are so many
techniques that
are being told to you that are
great to manage your stress.
They don't treat the
underlying cause of stress,
but they help you manage it.
And they're good, but one thing
on the list is go to nature.
Learn from nature.
Your body,
physiologically, is adapted
through tens of thousands of
years and hundreds of thousands
of years to the natural
environment from which we came.
Eat according to
nature because any time
you have a slight
disorder, anytime you
have a slight
nutritional deficiency,
anytime you're exposed
to toxins, all of those
are related to our departure
from what's natural.
We need to try to correct that.
And in nature we
have extreme variety
of foods that are
made by nature that we
would have had in nature in
their natural pristine state.
Today, how much of a
variety do we have in food?
You could go to all
of Google cafeterias,
you would still not have more
than 50 foods covering just
about the whole gamut.
50 vegetables, and spices,
and grains, and legumes,
and few other things
Not that much.
But if you go
foraging in nature,
as our predecessors did--
our ancestors foraged
all the time before
agricultural age--
you would have unlimited
number of foods
to choose from all the time.
And you would have
the unpredictability
of what would be
available, which keeps you
on your toes in a healthy way.
It keeps you excited about life.
So, please bring variety
into your life and please
go to nature to learn
from her, and not
just to use her as a
shelter from stress.
And if you do go
into nature, then you
start learning other
things because you
will see the different animals
and people that co-inhabit
that natural environment,
and you see what they do
and what they don't do.
That is true for learning
from other people.
What do they do?
What do they not do?
And what makes them
healthier than us,
is always an important question.
You know that 79 million
Americans have pre-diabetes.
That's a huge number.
You know that hundreds
of thousands of children
are being diagnosed,
before age 10, with cancer.
Pediatric cancer is
a fast growing trend
and most hospitals are
building special wings
for childhood cancer.
And we have one out of three
or four children on drugs
or diagnosed with a disease.
And almost all
the children today
have some allergies, or
asthma, autoimmune disease,
or immune suppression condition
that will never [INAUDIBLE]
of children.
So, many children are
diagnosed with learning
disorders, and autism,
and other conditions that
didn't used to be so popular.
Once, it was 1 in
10,000 children--
not too long ago, a
few decades-- and now
1 out of 49 children are
diagnosed as having autism.
What's happening to
the next generation?
Many of you are going
to have children,
if you don't have them already.
What's happening to our children
that makes them suddenly
the sickest children
have ever been?
Shouldn't we learn
something about what
is happening in other countries
to compare and contrast and see
what we can learn to save a
whole generation of children
in this country?
How do we do that?
How do we learn about the
health of our children
when they're all exposed
to the same factors,
such as we don't
have a control group.
If we want to do a
scientific study.
We can't.
We have to go somewhere else
where the children have not
been exposed to what children
here have been exposed to.
There have been
studies with children
who have moved from
one country to another,
and they saw
clearly, the children
who moved to an
affluent Western nation
to a more primitive,
more developing nation,
the earlier they move to
the newer place, the newer
residence, the more they
adopted the same diseases
and disorders, including
mental diseases,
of the new adoptive country
that they've joined.
That is a very
important observation.
So, if a child comes to the
United States from Ethiopia
when he or she is
only 6 years old,
they're going to be a lot
healthier than the local kids
because they had 6 years
in a primitive environment.
But if they come here at age
2 or age 1, or worse yet,
at age 6 months, they develop
all the medical, and mental,
and behavioral conditions
that are typically
in the modern country
that they've joined.
Shouldn't we try to ask
ourselves the question,
why is that the case.
What are we doing to children
that makes them so sick?
How do we study that
when in our country
all the children are
exposed to the same things?
So, if we asked ourselves,
is it because they're
exposed to too many
electromagnetic radiation
sources?
Is because they had
too many vaccines?
Is it because they eat
genetically modified organisms?
Is it because of something else?
Too much stress, perhaps?
They know when they are 2
years old that one day they
will work in Google.
They already are stressed out.
Who knows.
We don't have the answers.
But the only way to find out is
to start asking the questions
and doing some studies.
For that we need
a control group.
It just so happens that you
can create a control group
in a place that is far away
from the United States.
A place that is so
pristine, and so primitive,
so underdeveloped, that
most of the young children
have not been exposed to
what our children have
been exposed to.
If we can have a good
number of children
that we could study how
healthy they really are,
how lacking they are in mental
and behavioral disorders when
they go to school, how easy it
is to teach them, how excited
they are to go to school.
And they are
beautifully behaved.
They always are excited to
study, to learn new things.
When you see those children
and you fall in love with them,
you think, what a
great thing we can
do to impart some of their
health to other people
in developing countries
who are suffering
from all those modern diseases
of children that have never
been a part of our life until
just the last few decades.
Instead of just
worrying about it
and getting more
and more hospitals
to build more and
more cancer wings,
shouldn't we find the
causes and treat them
or avoid them or prevent them.
Preventive medicine
is not so heroic.
It's exactly the
same as preventing
suffering in children in
Nepal because while we create
the control group of
thousands and thousands
of children that can show
us the way, can guide us
into the light of health and
vitality, at the same time,
we can help them avoid the
horrific tragedy of childhood
trafficking.
15,000 children,
in Nepal alone, are
used in trafficking,
prostitution,
slavery every year, even now.
15,000 for a small country.
That's a huge tragedy.
Some of them are ending up as
domestic workers and slaves.
But most of them
end up in India,
where they're sold for
prostitution or slavery
and it's because their
environment is so poor, so
destitute, that they have
no capability of organizing.
Their communities
are fragmented.
Their families have
fallen apart, not just
because of a 10
year civil war that
left the country in
a desperate state,
but also because there
are no opportunities
in the rural areas of Nepal.
No socioeconomic
opportunity, no health
care available, no
educational opportunities,
so the children end up in
the fields all the time
and they are simple
and easy to pick.
And their parents are
totally illiterate,
so it's easy to come to
a parent and say we're
going to take your
child and give her
a great education in India and
put her in some boarding school
where she will learn
English and learn a vocation
and have a great
successful life.
If you are a parent that can't
offer anything to your child,
you'd fall for that.
And that child ends up
trafficked and suffering
horribly for the
rest of her life.
That can be easily prevented
with very little money
because prevention is
1,000 to 10,000 times more
effective than heroic
salvation after the fact.
So, instead of the expensive
emergency room medicine,
we're engaging in lifestyle,
nutritional, stress reduction
type of medicine, which
prevents the disease
at a tiny, tiny
fraction of the cost.
As I said, it's not heroic,
it's not so attractive and sexy,
because you can't
pinpoint those children
that you've saved
from trafficking.
But you make a real
impact, especially
if you go through
those societies,
in those remote areas,
and you help them organize
and then you make
them participate,
so it is more sustainable.
And you help rebuild
their communities
and build for them a
community center that
could take care of their
health and hygiene.
And start doing adult
literacy program
that teach the
parents some skills
and how to read and write.
And organize the women
in mother's groups
because the mother is really the
beginning and end of the family
caretaker, the educator.
Take care of those
in a sustainable way
and you don't need much money.
For only 8 and 1/2
dollars a month per child,
I can, by myself,
sustain 5,000 children
with Everest Learning
Academy-- which I really
want to applaud Google
because Google now
has its own matching program,
so people could contribute money
to the Ecopolitan
Eco-Health Community, which
supports the Everest Academy.
And I have some great news--
you're the first group
to hear about it-- that
we are now, finally,
recognized by the Nepali
Social Welfare Council
as an international NGO,
similar to the Peace Corps.
And we are just a few
people, not a government.
So, I invite you
to start thinking
about things bigger
than yourself.
That might be the thinking
person's stress relief.
Start thinking about what you
can do to make life better
on earth, not just for
yourself, but for others.
When you do that,
suddenly the stress
will melt way because
now you have a vision
and you have a purpose.
Think about it.
They've done studies with
people who are stressed,
and they said, yes,
stress will kill you.
But for some reason, some people
have the highest stress level
and they live the longest.
Studies have shown that.
It's a Paradox.
So, you have to start
looking, who are those people
because we want to
be like them, right?
And we find out that those
who live the longest,
despite severe stress,
are the ones who
are in charge of
their own destiny.
The ones who are not pushed
to a nine to five job,
but feel like they
create their own reality.
They manifest their own
dreams, visions, and missions.
Does it mean that the only
people who are the bosses
can live long?
Not necessarily.
Even people who
work a 9 to 5 job
can create a purpose
for themselves.
Can become the heroes
of their community
and of remote countries.
Can venture into new lands
where they can do some good.
And while doing that,
they think every day,
what am I doing today
that meets or gets me
a step closer to that purpose?
How do I make earth
a better place
from me, and for my children,
and for my friends' children
and great grandchildren?
How do we make this
a better place?
If you take a purpose to your
heart and start implementing,
on a daily basis,
whatever it is,
it will simply
overshadow the stress
of trying to simply preserve
your own ego in a society that
expects so much of you.
Where your responsibility
that you adopt
are so numerous just
because you need
to have affirmation
and acceptance
from your peers and
your family members.
Do something that's outside
of yourself and people
will leave you alone and they
will not expect much of you
because you'll be
doing something good.
Not just for yourself, not
just for your own pocket.
People who just work for
money have a lot of stress
because they always worry,
will they have enough money
to meet their next
consumerism goal.
What are they going to buy
next that they won't to use.
That will rot in their
garage-- three car
garage, which has
four cars in it.
What are those
people going to do?
Nothing.
They just have to keep
showing off to other people
how much they have.
So, instead you have
various options.
You can contribute to
worthwhile causes--
we're going to match you.
You work here-- or you
could decide to join.
You can start getting
into the activism mode.
We already have 5,000
children in our network
of 65 projects of schools,
and childcare centers,
and orphanages, and
community care centers
and we're growing rapidly.
We need somebody to be
creative and think and help
us create a technological system
that will allow us to collect
all the data we need to
collect about the health of all
the children in our network.
My goal is to get
to 100,000 children.
If you participate, as creative
individuals, and help us
find a system, a
method, that allows
us to collect all the
information that we need
to truly tabulate the mental,
emotional, social, and physical
health of our thousands
and thousands of children.
That would help us take better
care of our children in Nepal,
but it will also help
us create the data
that will allow us to start
implementing some changes that
are necessary so that the
hospitals will stop building
those cancer wings for children,
so that the pediatrician will
not have to treat so
many children with drugs,
so the children will not
be diagnosed with autism
and have to take various
drugs for ADD and ADHD.
That's not necessary.
We just need to
understand why is it
that 100,000
children-- God willing,
if we get 200,000 children
with the support of populations
that care, that have
the ability to care,
then we can really
help the whole world
because the modern
civilization is
where we have more problems
than we have over there.
As soon as they're
organized, as soon
they can take care
of themselves,
as soon as they have schools and
child care centers so that they
can get to work, as soon as
they learn to read and write.
We give them the
opportunity to acquire
a skill that will make
their life in rural Nepal
a lot better, a lot easier.
We can preserve their
culture, their ethnicity.
And you're welcome to visit.
You can come and check with us.
In March, we have some
people from Google
coming to represent Google.
And we will have other
people coming in October.
We do it twice a year.
You can come and join our
treks and see for yourself
what we do with the children.
You can volunteer or you could
just do it from your own home.
Help us create a system.
Let's design something
that allows technology
to collect the
information we need
to make this earth
a better place.
And In the meantime, we just
need to support it financially.
Financially we do the support
through the skin clinics,
which is something that I
created many, many years ago.
A way to eliminate and
prevent skin cancer, which
is the most common
cancer there is.
It is so easy to
prevent melanomas,
which kills tens of thousands
of Americans every year.
So easy, you just have to
eliminate the lesions that
might become cancer five years
from now or 10 years from now.
It's true prevention.
If you have 100 lesions on your
body-- little dark spots, flat,
where the sun won't
shine-- be aware.
Melanoma, the lethal skin
cancer everybody is afraid of,
always always
develops in the places
that have not been
exposed to the sun.
Surprising.
But it's not surprising,
we've known it for many years.
The information you're
getting from the establishment
is not accurate.
You have to open the
textbook yourself
and find out where
those melanomas occur.
And you'll be
surprised that they
occur on the scalp
under the hair,
behind your neck where
there's no sun exposure,
on your torso, and your
armpits, under your bikini line,
in the white spots that
have never seen the sun.
You better start
mooning the sun,
so the sun will shine where
it normally doesn't shine.
Get some sun exposure
in the various places,
but you have to do it regularly.
Because if you don't,
those white areas
that are irregularly exposed
once every six months,
that's where you will
develop your melanomas
and they start from little dark
spots that can gradually grow.
Catch all of those dark spots.
Eliminate them now.
It's so easy.
No surgery necessary.
No medical treatment necessary.
You can get rid of a hundred
of them in just one sitting.
And by doing that--
with any of the doctors
that I have trained, in
various places in the world,
to do this using my method--
by removing those skin lesions,
you prevent yourself from
developing skin cancer.
Also, the carcinomas
are very easy to treat--
that's a different
type of skin cancer.
Very easy to work with
those type of skin lesion
and catch them early.
Very good to remove
protrusions and growths,
which could develop as a
result of hormonal imbalance
or the result of
unhealthy nutrition.
And remember, if you get sick
because of unhealthy nutrition
or lack of sleep or
other types of exposures
or toxic exposures, the stress
that you have in your life
becomes far worse.
It's makes every
disease magnified.
So, you do want to eat really
well according to nature.
If you want to know
what I mean by nature,
go to the website
thetruthaboutyourfood.com
where I give 12 hours
of free information.
12 hours of lectures
that you get
for free--
thetruthaboutyourfood.com.
Then, you'll learn about healthy
nutrition according to nature
and according to science.
You do that, you
reduce your skin aging.
You make sure that you have
all the nutrients necessary,
like sulfur, which is a crucial
nutrient for the skin health
and for your hair health.
When you have not sufficient
sulfur in your body,
your hair starts falling and
becomes fragile and brittle.
And your skin starts
aging because it
loses its cytoskeletal
structure, that's
supported and makes
it plump and gives it
a body-- just like
when you were born
and had a plump face and
plump skin everywhere.
You want to retain that,
you have to eat really
food rich, rich,
rich, in antioxidants.
Every meal should be
rich in antioxidants
because today you're
exposed to so many toxins
that they increase the
[INAUDIBLE] damage.
It's not just the sun
that we blame on aging.
The sun is one source of
[INAUDIBLE] in our skin,
but our diet is
another big source.
Whenever you eat
rancid fats, you
damage your subcutaneous
fat under the skin,
and your skin ages prematurely.
If you want to remove
protrusion and growths
that occur as a
result of your diet
or if you want to improve
the hormonal balance,
so that you don't develop
tons and tons of skin tags
on your neck and
under your breast
and on your face, which you see
a lot of people suffering from.
And if you don't want to have a
rough spots and dark areas that
are caused by excessive
free radicals,
you have to make changes.
And then your body will be able
to handle stress a lot more.
You can take some
adaptogenic herbs,
which also help you handle
stress more effectively.
But again, they're
not addressing
the underlying problem.
So, I truly recommend
to go back to nature,
to learn from nature,
to come to the Himalayas
to see what we're
doing out there,
and get your stress level
down just by being in nature
and by adapting a
purposeful life.
That would make
your skin healthier,
your skin lesions less likely
to appear, you can easily
remove them and reduce the
stress of bad image problem
when you look in
the mirror, when
you have those huge
things on your nose.
They can easily be removed.
Don't tell me that you were born
with it; therefore, it's OK.
Because if you're
born with it, it's
been on you for a
longer amount of time
and it's been exposed
more to the elements.
It's even more risk.
And if it's caused by the
neurological imbalance that
makes some of those
protrusion occur,
you can improve your
neurological state
by removing them.
Improving the
balance of your body.
Your symmetry of
information that comes,
sensory information that
comes into your brain.
There are many reasons to
improve the skin appearance.
Not just your image.
Your skin is the
mirror off your health.
The integrity of this barrier
between the inside of our body
and the environment
outside of us.
That integrity is
crucial and it tells us
a lot about the integrity
of your entire body, which
is made of barriers.
The blood brain barrier,
the digestive barrier,
the cellular membrane,
as a barrier.
All of those barriers must be
healthy for you to be alive.
And of course, they have
to be healthy in order
for you to be healthy.
If the, skin as a barrier,
has lost its integrity,
also other barriers, which share
the same type of nutrition,
are going to lose
their integrity,
and you lose your health
on so many levels.
Keep your integrity of the
barriers, of your life,
of the purpose, of the
participation in making
this world, this earth,
a better place, and then,
your stress level will
go down because you
will learn what's really
important in life.
And you will truly stop
sweating the small stuff
that makes you worried
and stressed all the time.
You can do your work and
be happy with the results
because you know that
ultimately there's
something greater,
something bigger,
that you participate in to
leave a much better world
for future generation so that
the legacy that each one of you
has is a legacy worth having for
prosperity for many generations
into the future.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Are you working
with other organizations
like Soroptimist
International and the U.N.
with the children's issue?
And, if so, what companies?
Soroptimist has been around
since the 1920s, was founded
in Oakland by women that
weren't allowed into rotary.
And trafficking
of women and girls
has always been
something they've
worked on both internationally,
nationally, and locally.
They help women and children.
DR. TEL-OREN: At the
moment we are fairly young.
We've only been around
for 3 and 1/2 years.
And it's been so far
sort of a one man show.
And I have no time,
really, to get involved
with other organizations but
I wish I did have that time.
And I need more
people to help me
make the connection
because I'm limited.
I'm just one person who's seeing
patients nonstop and giving
lectures 250 times a year
in several continents.
I travel all the time, and
educate, and teach, and treat
and write, and travel,
and guide treks in Nepal.
I just don't have the
time, or the capability,
or the knowledge to do this this
administrative, important work,
that is connecting with
other organizations that
are pre-existing.
AUDIENCE: Well, I'd be happy
to connect you [INAUDIBLE].
DR. TEL-OREN: Thank you.
Any help is always
welcome, as long
as it doesn't add more
stuff on my table.
So, whoever wants
to help, please
help in a meaningful way
that can make things really
change for the better.
We have to activate
as many people
as we can to make this work.
We have a wonderful
staff in Nepal
that made it possible to grow
to 5,000 children in just 3
and 1/2 years.
It's just unbelievable.
It's above and beyond
my wildest imagination.
I had no idea that we
would become, suddenly,
an INGO, international
NGO, in Nepal.
We can have our own office
of the Ecopolitan community
from the United States.
We can have a full-time
office now in Nepal,
which we're going to
dedicate this March of 2014
because of this new honor that
has been bestowed upon us.
So, we are humbled by that, but
with a lot of responsibility.
We always want to
be sustainable.
We don't want to pluck
daughters, or girls,
or children from their
society and isolate them just
to save them.
We want to save the whole
community by organizing it
sustainably, so that all
the girls in the community
will not be trafficked.
Instead of just save 20 or
30, put them in the house,
and they will never go
back to their home society
because they have
been isolated from it
and they don't think
it's appropriate for them
to go back to the village.
And then, other girls in the
village who are less fortunate
end up trafficked instead.
Some organizations do that.
They have great
intention, but we
are trying to change society
by organizing the communities
with their own
participation, so they
can take pride in
what they're doing.
And we need help in that
direction, as much as we can.
What we mostly need
right now is money.
AUDIENCE: I have two
part question, actually.
Number one, is about the
trek that you mentioned
that happens in March and
October-- or November,
I'm not sure.
I want to learn a little
bit more about that.
And the second question
is, being born and raised
in Kathmandu, I would just like
to learn a little bit about how
you view the stress level,
the health quality, and just
quality of life.
Meaning, people that are living
in rural Nepal versus somebody
that's living in the city.
DR. TEL-OREN: Excellent
question and I often
lecture about it when
I have more time.
Differentiating what
happens to the children
who migrate to the city.
And it's usually
the young people
who are looking for
some opportunity who
go to Kathmandu where all
the tourists are so there's
a little more money,
there's more action,
there are more hospitals, and
more educational facilities
that provide
greater opportunity.
Unfortunately, when
they go to the city,
they also lose their culture.
Many times the ethnicities,
the beautiful Nepali culture,
gets dissolved into the
foreigners, and the pollution,
and the population overload
that occurs in the city.
And also, their health
starts deteriorating.
They start eating more
like the Westerners.
They want to emulate the
Westerners if they can.
So, they start eating a lot
higher on the food chain.
They start eating a lot less
plants and a lot more animals,
which they could never
afford in rural Nepal.
They start having
some of the symptoms
that I see with Americans.
A little more belly, a little
more diabetes, little more
skin disorders, they
start losing their hair.
I never see bald people who
are truly in rural Nepal,
but in the city I see
a lot of bald people.
All kinds of changes
happen when they
increase too much their
level of protein intake,
especially from animals sources.
And I'm not telling people
that they have to be vegan.
Nepalis are never vegan.
Even if they live
in rural Nepal,
they eat animals once in awhile.
But very rarely
can they afford it.
They reserve it for special
celebrations, special holidays.
Tihar, Dashain, and
other special festivals.
That's when they do that.
But as soon as they go to the
city and they can afford it,
they start partaking
of the cheap flesh that
comes from factory
farming of the animals.
And that could never
be healthy for them.
And we see the differences
in their health,
and in their mindset,
and their attitude.
I did some studies
with vitamin D level,
and even though Kathmandu
is still the city
and its polluted
and populated, I've
seen the highest level of
vitamin D in Nepal much higher
than anything I've seen in the
United States even in Florida.
And in Israel, the sunny country
of Israel, where 99% of people
are vitamin D deficient,
but in Nepal they
had a much higher,
healthier level of vitamin D
even though they use
umbrellas and there are foggy
times during the monsoon
season, and pollution,
and they don't like the sun
because they want to be whiter.
They're afraid of
becoming darker.
They want to be more
like the foreigners.
As a result, they don't
have that much sun exposure
but yet they still
have much higher level
of vitamin D, which
again is something
that could be interesting
for us to study.
Why is that?
Why are they healthier
on that level?
Because vitamin D protects
you from 25 types of cancer,
and diabetes, and obesity,
cardiovascular disease.
And people here are deficient.
And people here take
supplements and they still
have lower level
of vitamin D, then
Nepalis who don't even know
that there's such a thing
called vitamin D. And
they would definitely
never take supplements because
they can't afford them.
And they don't even
know what the test
is because they can't
afford the test.
So, I had to send their
blood from Kathmandu to India
to test their
vitamin D 11 level.
It doesn't exist it Nepal.
And they all have
vitamin D level far,
far higher than Americans do
in the southernmost states
of the United States.
So, this is another thing
that needs to be questioned.
We need to really do
some good study using
this amazing population
of kind-hearted people
who want to always
give you everything
they have to give with a smile,
no matter how little they have.
You could study
so much from them.
We inspire them just because
we could travel to visit.
But they can inspire us on
so many other levels that
help us open our
heart and our mind
to truly learn about
our world and be
happy with little consumerism,
with little materialism,
and learn to really enjoy
what is meaningful in life.
So, thank you for that question.
Did I answer it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DR. TEL-OREN: The trip.
It's very simple.
You go on nepali-children.org
or on trek4humanity.com.
One of those two.
And you read about it
and you send an email
and then you get information
about how to join the treks.
It's a 15 day trip, during
which you learn about Nepal--
not you, of course, because
you know so much about it.
But most people can
learn about Nepal
as if they were
there for four months
because during those 15 days,
I guide you incessantly.
You'll get tired of my accent.
You'll say, shut up already,
we learned enough for one
day about Nepal.
You will learn about
health, about nutrition,
about sustainability,
about socioeconomic issues,
about humanitarian
work, and you will also
learn a lot about
Nepal that you can't
learn in any regular trip
that is on the beaten path.
We go to places where
tourists never go .
We go to communities
that are never visited.
We go to areas in the
countryside in the Himalayas
that have amazing views and you
will never see another tourist.
Plus, we visit,
during those 15 days,
a lot of the communities that
the Ecopolitan communities
service through the
Everest Learning Academy.
You will meet the people.
We also go to Chitwan
National Park.
Come Some elephant ride in the
forest and see some animals
and get into a nice little
resort and go into some temple,
so you can learn
about the culture
and you learn about the people.
We also do our Touching
the Untouchable program.
That I started two
years ago to help
break the ancient caste
system and the prejudice
of the caste system.
Even though the government
of Nepal has abolished it,
in the rural part of the country
they still practice the caste
system, to some extent .
And we try to break
through that by blending
the different castes
together with the tourists,
with the groups, in a very
beautiful ceremony that allows
us to share with them
foods and drink and touch
them, and massage
them, and hug them.
And it shocks them because
they're the untouchables.
And they are so unexpecting
when that happens.
It's just an amazing
thing to see.
Every time we take
new groups so it's
a fresh new experience
with the Touching
the Untouchable program,
which I really hope
will end this caste
prejudice forever
in practice, as well as in law.
People who are interested
in joining the trek
can be sponsored by other
people on the website
trek4humanity.com
there is this option.
Just like people do the
walkathon, the MS-a-thon,
and so on, you could come
there and you're coming
is by itself
supporting the effort
because most of
the money actually
goes towards the activities of
the Everest Learning Academy.
And so, people can support
you, can sponsor you.
As many friends as you have
can sponsor you with as much
as they want, and that
allows you to come and also
to contribute more to Nepal and
also have the matching program
work with that.
So, it's a win-win-win
for everybody
and I really want
to thank Google
for being on that
matching program list.
I have to say that also Apple,
and Microsoft, and Oracle,
and Boeing Corporation are
all on our matching program
for the Ecopolitan
Eco-Health Community.
But Google has a great
program and we truly, truly
thank Google for having that.
MALE SPEAKER: For the
benefit of the audience,
I think that it will
be great to introduce
about the Himalayan,
high sulfur, black salts
that you bring in.
DR. TEL-OREN: Thank
you, I forgot about it.
I did mention the sulfur
earlier and how important
it is for the skin
health, but I forgot
to continue on that
idea, which is really
the sulfur-rich, black
salt from the Himalayas.
It's made in Nepal
in a factory that I
built in Kathmandu
that, basically,
has all of it's
profits supporting
the children and the activities
of the Everest Learning
Academy.
So, when you eat this
sulfur-rich salt,
which tastes like
eggs, by the way.
So you add it to a vegetable
and suddenly it tastes
like an egg salad.
You add it to a sandwich, it
tastes like an egg sandwich.
You add it to an avocado and
you want to melt from pleasure.
You can add it to anything.
It's kind of addictive
because it's so tasty,
but the sulfur is
extremely healthy
because it supports your
detoxification process,
called sulfation, and supports
the structure of your skin
and your hair, and nails, and
all of those structural organs
from ligaments,
tendons, to cartilage.
They all require sulfur.
So, this salt comes from
a very clean environment.
It is exactly nothing
more, nothing less,
than the pulverized
black crystals
of this special salt that
comes from the Himalayas.
And that's another way
to support our children
while supporting
your own health.
That's all it does.
Support the children
and your health.
MALE SPEAKER: You're
welcome to stay around.
Dr. T will be happy to
answer questions if you have.
And now let's give
applause to Dr. T.
DR. TEL-OREN: Thank you.